school starts for ccsd students in
exactly one week most are going back to
in-person learning but not all of them
yeah some of them are going to be
learning from home by choice the nevada
virtual academy says they've really seen
an uptick in students wanting to stick
to online learning victoria saha gives
us a look at why
it seems as though many people were
eager to get back to in-person
activities but for some students they
found out they were actually benefiting
from virtual learning and now they'll be
learning from behind the screen
permanently at nevada virtual academy's
orientation parents and students got a
glimpse of what the organization offers
when it comes to non-traditional ways of
schooling everything that's in the brick
and mortar classrooms we have is just
virtually executive director yolanda
hamilton says they established in 2007
and were associated with virtual
learning before the world's turn to it
in 2020. they have licensed teachers who
have class sessions every day from about
eight until four o'clock and they're
scheduled and the expectation is they
go to class though 2100 students will be
learning online those struggling with
academics are allowed to meet with
teachers in person but as to why
students are choosing virtual learning
can vary schools are scary right now
that's kind of what we come down to mom
jennifer kangelberg brought her 11 year
old son trey into monday's orientation
the thought of keeping her son safe at
home without having to worry about
potential school threats is a big reason
they're opting for virtual learning
everything that happened in hearing and
this and that he's just like i want to
go i don't want to go mom we'll be
lacking social interaction which is good
but nevada virtual academy offers plenty
of options for those who do want to
socialize with prom field trips clubs
and a graduation ceremony victoria saha
live local now
now we can also tell you that nevada
virtual academy is currently maxed out
on students that are enrolled there are
more than 2 000 already ready to start
the school year they also tell victoria
they still have about 100 people who are
on the waiting list as well